THE
MUSICAL >> IS ABOUT 4:00 A.M.
WE HAVE BEEN OUT SINCE
1:53:00 A.M.
IT IS JULY 3RD 2,021.
WE ARE IN NORTH AMERICA.
MOROCCO.
WE ARE ON THE INTERSTATE I-95.
NEAR EXIT 57.4.
>> Laura: JUST BIZARRE.
THIS WEEKEND, AT 11 HEAVILY
ARMED MEN WEARING TACTICAL GEAR
AND CLAIMING EXEMPTION FROM U.S.
LAW AND STATE LAW SHUT DOWN PART
OF THE MASSACHUSETTS INTERSTATE
DURING A TRAFFIC STOP.
THEY SAY THEY ARE PART OF A
GROUP THAT CALLS HIMSELF THE
BEFORE.
AND SAY THEY ARE ON THEIR WAY TO
"TRAINING."
THE ENTIRE ORDEAL ENDED AFTER AN
EIGHT HOUR LONG STANDOFF WITH
POLICE.
AND FOR REFERENCE, THE CAPITAL
BREACH LASTED ABOUT THREE HOURS.
SOME OF THE MEMBERS WERE
ARRAIGNED YESTERDAY IN WHAT
BECAME A PRETTY CHAOTIC.
TEARY TO
HEARING.
>> I'M NOT GUILTY
I AM A NATIONALIST
>> Laura: IS A REASONABLE
QUESTION TO ASK.
WHY ISN'T THIS BEING COVERED BY
THE MEDIA, AND WHAT ELSE DO WE
NEED TO KNOW ABOUT THEM?
JOINING ME NOW ARE TWO MEANT WE
KNOW THESE TYPES WELL.
TODD, FORMER MASSACHUSETTS STATE
TROOPER, AND CHRIS, FORMER FBI
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR.
TODD, YOU KNOW THIS GROUP.
I'D NEVER HEARD OF THIS GROUP OF
FOUR.
BUT YOU KNOW THEM WELL FROM YOUR
TIME AS A STATE TROOPER UP
THERE.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> I THINK WE FIRST NEED TO
POINT BACK TO SOVEREIGN CITIZEN
IDEOLOGY.
AND WHAT'S IMPORTANT ABOUT THAT
IS RECOGNIZING THE RECRUITMENT
TOOLS IN THE PROPAGANDA THAT IS
USED BY THE RISE OF THE MOORS
AND OTHER MOORISH GROUPS SUCH AS
THIS AND THAT THEY WILL POINT TO
THINGS SUCH AS THE TREATY
BAITING THE MIC DATING BACK TO
777.
I'VE ALSO SEEN DATES OF 1787
WHICH WAS THE TREATY BE TIME THE
UNITED STATES IN THE COUNTRY OF
MOROCCO.
WHAT THAT TREATY WAS ABOUT WAS
ABOUT MARITIME LAWS THAT ALLOWED
PRIVILEGE OF THE UNITED STATES
AND THE PRIVILEGES FOR THE
MOROCCAN COUNTRY -- THERE
MARITIME TO SUPPORT PRIVILEGES
BASED ON ECONOMIC, NOT TREATIES
FOR CITIZENS, BUT ECONOMIC
REASONS.
JUST LIKE SOVEREIGN CITIZENS
WILL ALSO USE MARITIME LAWS IN
ORDER TO CONFUSE LAW ENFORCEMENT
DURING MOTOR VEHICLE STOPS.
SO WHAT WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY DON'T RECOGNIZE
THEMSELVES AS SOVEREIGN
CITIZENS.
HOWEVER, THEIR IDEOLOGY IS
CLOSELY ALIGNED TO SOLVE YOUR
STOMACH SOVEREIGN CITIZEN
IDEOLOGY.
>> Laura: VERY BIZARRE.
HERE'S WHAT ONE OF THE MEN SAID
ABOUT THEIR SUPPOSED RIGHTS.
>> Laura: CHRIS, AGAIN, I
THINK MOST PEOPLE ARE JUST
SHOCKED BY THIS.
ALSO SHOCKED BUT MAYBE NOT ALL
THAT SHOCKED THAT THE MEDIA GAVE
IT A PRETTY MUCH A BIG YAWN OVER
THE WEEKEND.
AGAIN, WHAT DO AMERICANS NEED TO
UNDERSTAND ABOUT THIS?
>> THESE GROUPS EMERGED IN THE
'90s IN DIFFERENT ITERATIONS
OF THE MOORISH NATION, SOVEREIGN
NATION.
WHAT HAVE YOU.
I DEALT WITH THEM WHEN I WAS THE
HEAD OF THE FBI IN
NORTH CAROLINA PRAY THEY DON'T
RECOGNIZE ANY AUTHORITY
WHATSOEVER.
BUT THEY ARE BASICALLY A
CRIMINAL ORGANIZATION OR A SET
OF CRIMINAL ORGANIZATIONS THAT
WRAP THEMSELVES IN SOME
CONVOLUTED POLITICAL IDEOLOGY.
BASICALLY TO JUSTIFY COMMITTING
CRIMES.
AND THE CRIMES THEY COMMIT, THEY
ARE PROLIFIC FRAUDSTERS.
THEY WILL TAKE OVER SOMEONE'S
HOME, FILE QUITCLAIM DEEDS AND
MOVE INTO THE HOME WHILE THEY
ARE NOT THERE.
THEY COMMIT TAX FRAUD, FALSE TAX
RETURNS.
THEY KILLED OVER A DOZEN POLICE
OFFICERS SINCE 2002.
IN PARTICULAR, BATON
BATON ROUGE, LOUISIANA.
ONE INDIVIDUAL KILLED THREE
OFFICERS AND KILLED THREE
OTHERS.
BUT THEY PRESENT A CLEAR AND
PRESENT DANGER TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND NOBODY
SHOULD TAKE THEM LIGHTLY.
THEY ARE IN SOME BENIGN
POLITICAL ORGANIZATION.
THAT'S JUST A FACADE.
>> Laura: AND TODD, ANOTHER
MEMBER SPOKE ABOUT WHAT THEY
CLAIM WERE THERE TRAVEL PLANS.
>> OUR VEHICLE IS FULL OF
CAMPING EQUIPMENT WHICH SUPPORTS
HOW WE ARE GOING TO OUR PRIVATE
LAND TO TRAIN WHICH IS OUR
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHT.
>> Laura: WHAT KIND OF
TRAINING ARE THEY DOING AND THEY
SEEM TO BOTH CITE THE
CONSTITUTION AND THEN KIND OF
CLAIM THEY ARE NOT REALLY
BEHOLDEN TO ANY LAWS THAT ARE
PASSED CONSTITUTIONALLY.
IT'S A VERY ODD DYNAMIC.
OF PICKING AND CHOOSING WHAT
THEY WILL BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE BY
AND TWO.
>> AND THAT'S THE ARGUMENT, THEY
SAY THEY ARE NOT -- THAT THEY
ARE NOT ANTIGOVERNMENT, BUT TO
CHRIS'S POINT, THEY SPUR TO RUN
WITH THEIR LANGUAGE, THEIR
IDEOLOGY.
THEY MAKE REFERENCE TO THAT THEY
ARE INDEPENDENT OF THE LAW, NOT
ANTIGOVERNMENT.
TO ME IF YOU ARE NOT FOLLOWING
THE LAWS OF THE U.S., THEN YOU
ARE ANTIGOVERNMENT.
BUT REGARDING THE IDEOLOGY AS
THEY WOULD SPEAK TO TRAVELING,
THEY SAY IT'S THEIR GOD-GIVEN
RIGHT TO TRAVEL, THAT'S WHY THEY
DON'T NEED DRIVERS LICENSES.
SO AGAIN, THE SPLIT HERE IS THEY
FIND THIS WAY TO MANIPULATE
WORDS AND MAKE THE WORDS
BASICALLY JUSTIFY THEIR ACTIONS.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING WITH -- ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, THE FLAG AND ALL
THESE DIFFERENT THINGS.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A PROPAGANDA
RECRUITMENT TOOL.
THEY ARE GOING TO USE AND
LEVERAGE THIS TO GAIN OTHER
PEOPLE AND INTERESTS.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY ARE OUT
THERE.
THERE ARE CONFLICTING NUMBERS,
BUT WATCH AND SEE THE LEVEL OF
INTEREST THAT THIS MOST RECENT
INCIDENT OVER THE WEEKEND WILL
GAIN THE ATTENTION.
>> Laura: WE HAVE HEARD A LOT
FROM OUR FBI DIRECTOR AND FROM
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES ABOUT THE GROWING
WHITE SUPREMACISTS THREAT IN THE
UNITED STATES.
GROWING DOMESTIC TERRORIST
THREAT.
I'VE NEVER HEARD OF THESE GUYS
MENTIONED AND YET IN DAYTONA A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO IN FLORIDA,
A BLACK PARAMILITARY INDIVIDUAL
SHOT AND KILLED A DAYTONA POLICE
OFFICER.
THIS DOESN'T FIT THE NARRATIVE
OF CHARLOTTESVILLE OR THE WHITE
SUPREMACISTS AND EVERYTHING THAT
THEY OBSESS ON, SO I OWNED WE
REALLY UNDERSTANDING MORE ABOUT
THEM AND WHY DOESN'T THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SPEAKING OUT ABOUT
THIS?
>> AS YOU MENTIONED, THEY
PRESENT A DANGER TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY DON'T RECOGNIZE ANY
AUTHORITY, BUT YET, THEY ARE NOT
RECOGNIZED AS EXTREMIST.
EVEN SOUTHERN POVERTY LAW CENTER
BACKED OFF ON THAT.
THEY HAD BEEN CLASSIFIED AS A
SOVEREIGN NATION AND ALMOST HAD
TO MAKE DOMESTIC TERRORIST GROUP
BUT THEY BACKED OFF AND SAID
THEY ARE ANTIGOVERNMENT.
I DON'T KNOW WHY IT DOESN'T CUT
BOTH WAYS.
IT SHOULD.
THIS IS A BLACK EXTREMIST GROUP
PRIMARILY, AND WE CAN COME OUT
AND SAY THAT.
THEY DON'T RECOGNIZE ANY
AUTHORITY.
I REALLY THINK THEY ARE MORE A
CRIMINAL ORGANIZATION THAN THEY
ARE POLITICAL, IDEOLOGICAL BASE.
I THINK THAT YOU SAID TO JUSTIFY
THEIR CRIMES BECAUSE THAT'S
PRET